Cambodia is a country with a rich history,...
...amazing food and a decent nightlife scene...
...similar to its neighbors Vietnam and Thailand,...
...but it's one that is a lot less developed and less visited.
The cost of living in this country is cheap.
You can easily spend a month in Cambodia with just 1,000 dollars.
There are some one-off expenses such as the three-day pass to Angkor Wat...
...which is currently set at 62 dollars, and diving trips that add up,...
...but there will also be days of riding bicycles in a small village...
...and eating cheap and delicious food.
You can spend around 1 to 3 dollars for a local meal at a restaurant or on the street.
Accommodations won't cost you much more.
Get a double room with a fan for 4 dollars, and an air-conditioned room for 6 to 8 dollars.
You can choose what you spend, of course,...
...and a decent hotel room will still only be around 15 to 20 dollars.